how'd you feel did you watch Trump
announce his big candidacies back I'm
more concerned with climate change hey
that's where my head goes to don't waste
your time on this subject we could be
talking about something that we might be
able to do something about
people could work together from around
the world to help and solve what it is
that we got going on here but don't you
think that you have to elect the right
people who are concerned about climate
change I mean it really helps if you got
the right leader but the thing is the
people
need to recognize
that the media is not covering this
story
I have a theory that the media not
covering climate change is what's
responsible for the uneasiness and the
anger in the people
because the people of the country know
they've heard little things here and
there this could be the end times
15 or 20 years is all we got
our children's life is not going to be
like ours was and their children's life
we don't even know about
you you got those kind of thoughts going
on in the background but nobody really
talks about it
nobody says anything
the news you know all the different uh
pundits they they don't talk about that
like they talk about you know what we
were just talking about we changed the
subject because it's so boring who cares
about those people
what's really important is what's going
on in the world and what's going on on
this planet and what we have to do to
save it for our children and for for
their children why do you think the
media doesn't cover this in other words
you're right it's not exciting it's not
it's not the easiest stupidest simplest
thing that they can do that has an
episode every day with a new uh you know
where some [ __ ] does a stupid thing
and then they talk about it and they go
back and forth and have an attitude
about left and right and do that whole
thing that is so boring those people are
so out of it they have absolutely no
idea what news is
sitting here and discussing Trump versus
Biden or it's all nonsense in other
words there's nothing more important All
We Got Is this planet that's it
you have to have that that's my attitude
that's how I feel that's what's
important to me that's what the that's
what my record is about although it's
not a negative thing it's not I'm not
mad about it I'm going it's a chance for
us to come together it may be the best
thing I've ever done and I'm only saying
that because I think so but I'm not sure
but it's also the newest thing I've ever
done so I'm really engaged in it so I
don't know my perspective may be screwed
up but the thing is
it's very Musical and it's very light
and it's very positive
which is weird because what you're
talking about is a really heavy topic
you know I mean yeah you'd think you
would have gotten sort of depressed and
angry what about the feeling now what
about the feeling of the people think
about all these people trying to do the
right thing at the same time together
around the world think about these world
leaders this fictional scene where
they're all talking about the same thing
the thing that the thing that's
confronting Humanity
think about world leadership and all the
leaders of all the countries agreeing
that there's one thing there's really a
bummer and we got to do an obvious thing
to fix it and we could do it in every
country we could do it in Pakistan so we
wouldn't have the floods
we could do it in India so we wouldn't
have whatever they have there floods
fires whatever the hell it is all of
these things we could be fixing this we
could do it together everybody could do
it all the leaders could do it it's
right there
right in front of us there's nothing
hiding it
except the media won't talk about it
because they're self-serving
and they're they got to get out of that
Vibe and start serving the people and
doing the right thing